hello i'm carlo and i'm gabrielle and
we're on our ateneo study tour we are
here to discover the beautiful city of
trier hey but we're not alone we're with
our classmates
the roamer architecture is very very
nice
the dark stones are very interesting
it's so different from what i've seen
before in the philippines
it's very big
it's bigger than our churches in manila
and it's right beside the there's two
churches here so the cathedral and then
another church right there so it's very
unique
one
two three
we try not to step on the canals because
there's this rumor if um you step on the
canals it will rain
yesterday our friend rommel stepped on
the canal of saint peter and it rained
because of him
i noticed that all these sculptures they
don't have noses
it's very
you go strange
guys
this is the biggest treasure i've ever
seen so much gold coins
i wish i had this money
there's so much gold
it says here that it's
18.5 kilograms heavy
and it's very heavy
i can't even lift it
we don't have these kinds of flowers in
the philippines
but they are very beautiful and the best
part about this is that you could blow
them up
we're on a tour boat in the mosul river
and then it's gonna cruise downstream
and upstream
so that's our day in three year and as
you can see we all had a great time